devin williams is on national league
rookie of the year
and harry doyle let's go it's an honor
and a privilege to present the 2020
jackie robinson rookie of the year award
in the american league
to kyle lewis welcome to the club kyle
yes sir thank you guys thank you guys
you know to have a black hitter and a
black pitcher in the same year is
something that is something out of
storybook or something
all right gentlemen uh honored to be
here with
you guys for rookie of the year so i
feel like i'm left out the party to be
honest i'm looking like you know i mean
ryan i was there with you when you
wanted doc
i was a youngster watching you trying to
be like you
you know the big cook and just filthy
devin kyle the newest generation the
first to do it since 84
having two black young men win rookie of
the year i mean it's an honor
i hope you guys understand what that
means to us as a community
obviously as players and role models
but in light of everything what that has
really meant i personally feel that
winning this year had
a slightly different meaning that it
would have would have had in the past
and a lot of everything with that being
said it's almost like and it's sad that
once you know one rookie of the year is
announced and he's
black he's african-american he knows
who's up in the other league
you start to think it's impossible like
why like we we've been almost
trained and programmed to be well we
have enough
you know we got one don't don't ask for
more than that
you got you won so be happy with that
what does it mean to you to win given
the environment
um that we're living in today and i'll
start with you devin
i think for both of us from both sides
of the game you know me on the mound and
him as a position player
to uh be an example for these kids out
here you know and uh
kind of be a light and show them that
this is a game that
that's here for them as well i think
that was a really special
moment okay luke it means a lot for me
you know being with my family and uh
and seeing him win you know as i was
getting set up
you know brought tears to my eyes just
to see especially a black pitcher you
know that's
you know rare thing man so that's super
special and uh super proud of
you know the the way that we're able to
represent the game
and the messages you receive after that
you know really mean a lot put it into
perspective you know even in ways i
probably wasn't able to
understand you know until afterwards and
just being able to
move around in the community now see the
kids see the reception that they have
you know when
you show up in the inspiration that they
get
[Music]
you know it continues to put it into
perspective every day so
i just continue to try to you know carry
that on and blessed to be the next thing
excited to see who comes next cause you
know to have a black hitter and a black
pitcher
in the same year is just something that
is something out of storybook or
something
and doc what was your experience like i
mean you were it was it hadn't been done
since the 84th season but was it the
same way like feeling that
obviously when anytime we win something
that as black people and it's done on
both sides of the aisle
there's a sense of black pride we talk
about black pride but
it's hard to explain what it feels like
it's hard to put in words it's something
you feel and you you will never forget
that feeling
so that in 84 when you were going
through it
and seeing it happen and living it what
was that experience like and
you know seeing it happen again so many
years later
how do you feel about these two young
men that went about and won the awards
my first congratulations both to you
guys i think
um for me like you say i've been 84 with
myself and alvin davis
great to see man i'm a big fan of the
game they just put
extra extra pride on top of it when you
see two guys especially
like [ __ ] win that award babe i think
i'll win it as well it's just a great
game in the team
you know these guys a big piece
you have a history or at least your
family has a history
your parents and you know maybe not a
lot of people you know about this
i'm gonna leave it at that you know i
come from
a family my parents were both born and
raised in birmingham alabama
came up in civil rights movement pops
was was out there you know
getting getting chased down by the dogs
and hit with the hoses and everything
so understanding that dynamic
of you know where we come from
as a people that strength that resolve
that resilience um is what's helped
shape me into to who i am
today um i try to pay it back
forward as much as i can um
you know being able to talk to to to
young players young black players and
letting them know
because in seeing what's going on in
today's society and
understanding where it was where the
game was when doc
came up to where jimmy where you and i
came up to where the game is with
devin and kyle is i mean it's just been
strides and strides and strides in the
right direction currently today because
all the stuff that's going on today is
stuff that's been going on
now the light has been shined on it even
more than what it ever did
because everybody's media these cell
phones tell
you know the the videos and the cell
phones and all that kind of stuff
you can't hide from the video if the
video shows you doing this
they got you on video so i think
in today's society to your question also
jimmy about
uh is the game different in baseball
uh i think it's different because the
light has been
shined on and you still people today
being like just shut up and play
well let me tell you something i'm a man
first
and foremost yes i put this uniform on
and yeah this is how i pay my bills but
i'm a man first and foremost and i
damn sure want to be treated like one
and that's what it's all about man is is
regardless of what you do i don't care
if you change oil i don't care if you
work on roofs man you are a man and you
are a woman
and you should be treated as a human
being with all kind of respects
regardless of what that paycheck looks
like devin and kyle
how did what happened this summer black
lives matter
um how did that connect everyone
obviously we know about the players
alliance
how that all came about now we're all in
on a group whether we're out of the game
coming to the end or just starting but
how did you guys
as black players find one another
connect
communicate and say you know
what can we do yeah i think it just it
brought
the the black community and baseball
closer together you know what i mean
like
everyone was just kind of there for each
other you know
if you need something you can always
reach out like i mean i can't even tell
you how many texts i got like that from
other players like in the game or
retired guys like and i mean it was just
a good support system for me to have
especially being a rookie
you know being the only black guy in the
in my clubhouse since
well kane he opted out so i was the only
black guy
it was good to have people like cece and
some others like reach out to me you
know just
support him you know i give a lot of
credit you know the club
you know for doing what they could as
well as far as making efforts
and uh me and devin met on a zoom call
you know speaking about being in
baseball you know different
different experiences that we had you
know growing up
and then speaking about it and just
trying to connect you know
african americans in the game the best
way we knew how so
i'm appreciative of them for setting
that up as well and you know there's a
lot of different habits
you know started to show themselves
whether it be group chats
whether it be meetings in the hotel you
know i think guys really started to
understand the magnitude and put that
sense of urgency on
us sticking together and having each
other's back you know and uh
it really started to show itself
throughout the year in a lot of
different ways
and i want to go back to you because you
know you're the generation before
before me for rhyme for all of us um the
activism that
is is allowed today versus back in the
80s
um what is the difference that you see
that you live
through then and that although you're
not in uniform you live through because
you're a black man today
we're talking 86 the guys on our team
was pretty close but at that time it's
just different generations
we had some situations where it kind of
got heated you know race to comets be
made on the bus from
alcohol what have you and they say they
apologize but
totally different now i like to see the
closeness now um
it is different we did have more blacks
i think in my generation
i came up in 84 for teams and different
teams but it is now i think now
it's almost like one to the theme i
think i heard um
totally different so it's probably more
i would think now than what we had
because we did have at least three or
four
that we can hang out with at times um on
the road
or just have those conversations you
know just talking you know our talk or
whatever
um not to determine anything like that
but you know sometimes microbes just
want to talk about
things we have four or five guys you
could do that with where now
you know these guys they probably know
better than i do but they don't seem
like they have many other things
sometimes don't even have any you know
they have the latin ball players but not
bike balls
i want to go here next um with our
baseballs version of colin kaepernick
and that's bruce maxwell who much like
you devin
was was solo i mean one brother on a
team
a clubhouse full of people that don't
really understand the impact
of what's happening and today it's a
black man so every time we leave the
house
we're looking over our shoulder we're in
the big leagues we made money
we see likes we still get nervous it
doesn't matter how much money
we have it doesn't matter how much we've
accomplished
when we take off and leave our houses
we know all they see is the skin color i
might be the nicest person in the world
i might be the meanest person in the
world it doesn't matter this skin color
means something to everyone else so then
you have bruce maxwell who decides
i'm going to take a need for a national
anthem and stand up for what he believes
in
and to be honest no one had his back
as rookies i don't expect you guys to
come out and say just to say anything
that that's
it's kind of hard to say that's not your
place but
it's it's kind of not your place to be
on the forefront of that but
he had to do something that he believed
in a rookie
you know taking me close to san
francisco at open bay area
uh where it happened with colin
kaepernick how do you feel about
the way he was sacrificed and having an
opportunity to come back to the a's
and saying i don't want it i just think
you know at that time guys were
were scared you know what i mean scared
to support that
because of the backlash i mean you saw
what happened with him you saw it happen
with kaepernick
but we don't really hear about him that
much because he's not
he's not the name that kaepernick is
like he kind of just got pushed to the
side and
forgotten about and you know some that's
really sad to see but
i also really respect the fact that he
he declined the offer to come back
i think it did set an example for you
know this year being able to
you know understand the magnitude of the
decision like that
and being able to connect with other
players you know to prepare
to try to make a unified stance you know
i think it definitely helped pave the
way for that
and so you know that's something that's
always valuable you know moving forward
is
us understanding that you know when one
of us
wants to try to make a stance you know
let's come together
and let's try to do it the right way in
a way that you know is going to be heard
with unity
so that one player can't be you know
painted as an outlier or you know push
to the side
you know it for us started with jackie
robinson having to go through
and take all the abuse and have the
courage
to not fight back although he fought
back in different ways but not to
physically
go on the field and knock somebody's
seat out because you know he wanted to
do that
jackie wasn't a soft dude let's let's
just make that clear
but going with the history of baseball
from that time
to blacks have an explosion of baseball
to dwindling down to now you see teams
with not even
one black player on it i've asked myself
you know what would i what i've taken a
knee
i've been a current player and honestly
i i don't know
but the reality of it is we all have to
answer that question if i do this
what will be the consequence so to be
out there without that support
hoping that just be you know because
you're standing up for a cause that
everyone is going to have your back
that i'm going to do this for us and
then to find out
on the other side everybody is looking
out for themselves
even if that's not true that's that's
what it feels like you're out there
on your own had that not happened
kaepernick and then bruce and then
everything that happened
with baseball of activism activism and
baseball even
existed like it is today no celebrating
with me but the thing that happened
when that stuff took place and the thing
that hurt me the most was not that
everybody was saying that oh you must
have done something wrong
because we're black you must have done
something wrong that part bothered me
and not this stuff took place catholic
just to bring
attention to what's going on and
unfortunately we had a couple others
that lose their lives
you know with uh floyd and others to get
their attention
and then with the protesting the marches
having white people march also bringing
attention to
what's going on okay now just doing what
you're comfortable with doing
i don't think we have to do anything i'm
just really smart
that before you gotta do it because it
makes guys important
do what you feel comfortable with and
you always understand it before you do
something
it's just something i really want to do
and consequences
i'm behind that where there's good
consequences of backgrounds but and
understand that and ask yourself
am i going to be okay with this my
family will be okay with this
then you take the stance but just doing
what you feel thoughts right in your
heart
carry on the message